I always say to my students and that
being a scientist is like being an
explorer and I really mean that because
in a sense I think in science we explore
the world the universe around us some
people look at big things and other
people look at very small things but in
a sense we're all trying to understand
the world around us in a sense we're
looking in little corners in places that
nobody has ever looked before and that's
a lot of fun so we go to work and we
have problems that were interested in
when and when I say we for my kind of
work I run a laboratory and that means
there are people who have come to the
laboratory to work with me because
they're interested in the same problems
it's like a family if you will
interested in problems and we get
excited about things and we figure out
how to do experiments to test them